Huxley avait peur que nous devenions une culture banale.
Orwell avait peur que la vérité
ne nous soit dissimulée,
et Huxley craignait que nous nous noyions
dans un océan de choses sans importance.
En un mot, c'est un choix entre
être regardé par Big Brother
et regarder Big Brother.
(Rires)
Mais ça ne doit pas forcément se passer comme ça.
Nous ne sommes pas des consommateurs passifs de données et de technologie.
Nous façonnons le rôle qu'elles jouent dans nos vies
et la façon dont nous leur donnons sens.
Mais, pour ce faire,
nous devons prêter autant d'attention à notre façon de penser
qu'à notre façon de programmer.
Nous devons nous poser des questions, des questions difficiles,
pour aller au-delà de compter les choses,
et commencer à les comprendre.
Nous sommes constamment bombardés d'histoires
sur la quantité de données dans le monde,
mais quand il s'agit de mégadonnées
et des défis pour les interpréter,
la taille n'est pas tout.
Il y a aussi la vitesse à laquelle elles bougent,
et la grande variété des types de données.
Voici juste quelques exemples :
des images,
des textes,
des vidéos,
des sons.
Ce qui unifie ces différents types de données,
c'est qu'elles sont créées par des personnes
et qu'elles nécessitent un contexte.
Un groupe de scientifiques de données
de l'Université d'Illinois à Chicago,
dénommé « Collectif Média Santé »
qui ont travaillé au Centre de Contrôle des Maladies [CDC]
pour mieux comprendre comment
les gens discutent à propos d'arrêter de fumer,
comment ils parlent des cigarettes électroniques,
et sur ce qu'ils peuvent faire ensemble
pour les aider à arrêter.
Ce qui est intéressant, si on veut comprendre
comment les gens parlent de fumer,
d'abord, on doit commencer par comprendre
ce qu'ils entendent par « fumer ».
Sur Twitter, il y a quatre catégories :
numéro un : fumer des cigarettes ;
numéro deux : fumer de la marijuana ;
numéro trois : côtelettes fumées ;
et numéro quatre : femmes chaudes et sexy.
(Rires)
Ensuite, on doit réfléchir sur
comment les gens parlent de cigarette électroniques.
Il y a tant de façons différentes d'en parler,
comme vous pouvez le voir sur la diapositive,
c'est une requête bien complexe.
Et ceci nous rappelle que
le langage a été créé par des personnes,
et les personnes sont désordonnées, et nous sommes complexes,
et que nous utilisons des métaphores, de l'argot, du jargon
et nous faisons ça 24h/24, 7j/7, dans plein, plein de langues,
et aussitôt qu'on se décide, on change tout à nouveau.
Donc, est-ce que ces annonces du CDC,
ces publicités à la télé qui montraient
une femme avec un trou dans la gorge,
qui étaient très crues et troublantes.
ont-elles finalement eu un impact
sur la décision des gens d'arrêter de fumer ?
Le Collectif Média Santé a respecté les limites de leurs données
mais ils ont réussi à conclure que ces annonces
- que vous avez probablement vues -
ont eu pour effet d'induire les gens
à un processus de réfléxion
qui peut avoir eu un impact sur leur comportement futur.
Ce que j'admire et reconnais de ce projet,
en dehors du fait qu'il est basé
sur des besoins humains réels
est que c'est un exemple fantastique de courage
dans un océan de choses sans importance.
Ainsi, ce ne sont pas uniquement les mégadonnées
qui représentent un défi d'interprétation, car, soyons honnêtes,
nous, les humains, nous avons un riche historique
de prendre n'importe quelles données, même petites,
et de tout gâcher.
Il y a plusieurs années, vous vous en rappelez peut être,
l'ancien Président Ronald Reagan
fut violemment critiqué pour avoir dit que
les faits étaient des choses stupides.
Soyons honnêtes, ce fut à peine un lapsus.
Il voulait citer John Adams, dans sa défense des soldats anglais
lors du procès du massacre de Boston,
disant que les faits étaient des choses tenaces.
Mais je pense qu'il y a un peu de
sagesse fortuite dans ce qu'il a dit,
car les faits sont tenaces,
et, parfois, ils sont aussi stupides.
J'aimerai vous raconter une histoire personnelle
sur pourquoi cela me tient tant à cœur.
J'ai besoin de respirer.
Isaac, mon fils, quand il avait deux ans,
a été diagnostiqué d'autisme.
C'était un petit gars heureux, drôle,
aimant, affectueux,
mais, les scores des évaluations de son développement
qui considèrent des choses comme le nombre de mots --
à cette époque là : zéro --
de gestes communicatifs, et de contact visuel minimal,
plaçaient son développement
au niveau de celui d'un bébé de 9 mois.
Ces diagnostics étaient effectivement corrects,
mais ils ne racontaient pas tout.
Environ un an et demi plus tard,
quand il avait presque 4 ans,
je l'ai trouvé, un beau jour, devant l'ordinateur
cherchant sur Google des images de femmes
épelées "f-a-m-e-s."
Et j'ai fait ce que tout parent obsessif aurait fait :
J'ai cliqué immédiatement le bouton « précédent »
pour voir quoi d'autre il avait cherché.
C'était, dans l'ordre : hommes,
école, bus et ordinateur.
J'étais stupéfaite,
car on ne savait pas qu'il savait épeler,
et encore moins lire. Donc je lui ai demandé :
« Isaac, comment as-tu fait ça ? »
Il m'a regardé très sérieusement et dit :
« Écrit dans le cadre. »
Il s'apprenait lui-même à communiquer,
mais nous cherchions au mauvais endroit,
et c'est ce qui se passe quand les évaluations
et les analyses donnent plus d'importance à une mesure --
dans ce cas, la communication verbale --
et en sous-estiment d'autres, comme la résolution créative de problèmes.
Communiquer était difficile pour Isaac,
et il avait donc trouvé une astuce
pour découvrir ce qu'il avait besoin de savoir.
Quand on y pense, ça semble logique,
car formuler une question
est un processus vraiment complexe,
mais il a réussi à faire un grand pas
en tapant un mot dans un cadre de recherche.
Et ce court instant
a eu un profond impact sur moi
et sur notre famille.
Car ça nous a aidé à changer nos références
sur ce qu'il lui arrivait,
à nous préoccuper un peu moins et à apprécier davantage
sa débrouillardise.
Les faits sont des choses stupides.
Et ils sont vulnérables à une mauvaise utilisation,
délibérée ou non.
J'ai une amie, Emily Willingham, qui est une scientifique.
Elle a écrit un article pour Forbes
il n'y a pas longtemps, intitulé
« Les 10 choses plus bizarres reliées à l'autisme. »
Il y en a toute une liste.
On blâme Internet pour tout , n'est ce pas ?
Et bien entendu, les mères, parce que voilà.
Attendez, ça n'est pas tout,
Il y a toute une liste dans la catégorie « mère »,
comme vous voyez, une liste très complète et intéressante.
Personnellement. je suis vraiment fan de
« tomber enceinte près des autoroutes ».
La dernière est intéressante,
car le terme « mère réfrigérateur »
était en fait l'hypothèse initiale
de la cause de l'autisme,
il signifie quelqu'un de froid et sans amour.
À ce stade, vous devez penser:
« Ok, Susan, on comprend,
on peut prendre des données et leur faire dire ce qu'on veut. »
Et c'est vrai, c'est absolument vrai,
mais, le défi c'est que
nous avons cette chance
d'essayer de leur donner nous-mêmes un sens car, franchement,
les données ne se créent pas leur sens. C'est nous qui le faisons.
Donc, en tant qu'hommes d'affaires, et consommateurs
en tant que patients, en tant que citoyens
nous avons la responsabilité, je pense,
de passer plus de temps
à se concentrer sur nos capacités de pensée critique.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'à ce moment de notre histoire,
comme nous l'avons entendu souvent,
nous pouvons traiter des milliards d'octets de données,
à la vitesse de la lumière,
et nous avons le potentiel de prendre de mauvaises décisions
bien plus rapidement, efficacement,
et avec un impact bien plus grand que par le passé.
Super, n'est ce pas ?
Donc, ce que nous devons faire, au contraire,
c'est consacrer un peu plus de temps
sur des choses comme les sciences humaines,
la sociologie, les sciences sociales,
la rhétorique, la philosophie, l'éthique,
car elles nous fournissent le contexte qui est si important
pour les mégadonnées, et parce que
elles nous aident à devenir de meilleurs penseurs critiques.
Car, en fin de compte,
si je repère un problème dans une controverse,
il importe peu qu'il soit exprimé en mots ou en chiffres.
Cela signifie que nous devons nous enseigner
à détecter ces biais d'interprétation,
et ces fausses corrélations
et à être capables de repérer un recours clairement émotionnel
à 30 mètres de distance.
Car si un événement se produit après un autre
ça ne veut pas forcément dire qu'il s'est produit à cause du premier.
Et, si vous me permettez d'oser un instant,
les romains appelaient cela « post hoc ergo propter hoc »
« à la suite de ceci, donc à cause de cela ».
Cela signifie mettre en doute les disciplines telles que la démographie.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elles sont basées sur des hypothèses
sur qui nous sommes,
fondées sur notre sexe, notre âge, notre lieu de vie,
au contraire des données sur ce que nous pensons et faisons vraiment.
Et, puisque nous avons ces données,
nous devons la traiter avec un contrôle approprié de confidentialité
et avec le consentement du consommateur,
et au-delà de ça, nous devons être clairs
quant à nos hypothèses,
aux méthodes que nous utilisons,
et à notre confiance dans les résultats.
Comme disait mon prof d'algèbre au lycée :
« Montre tes calculs,
car si je ne sais pas quelles étapes tu as suivies,
je ne sais pas les étapes tu n'as pas suivies,
et, si je ne sais pas les questions que tu t'es posées,
je ne sais pas quelles questions tu n'as pas posées. »
Ce qui signifie, vraiment,
nous poser la plus difficile des questions :
Est ce que les données nous montrent vraiment ceci
ou est-ce que les résultats nous font nous sentir
plus performants et plus à l'aise ?
Donc, à la fin du projet,
le Collectif Média Santé a réussi
à trouver que 87% des tweets
sur ces annonces anti-tabac très dérangeantes
exprimaient la peur.
Mais ont-ils conclu qu'elles avaient
vraiment fait les gens arrêter de fumer?
Non. C'est de la science, pas de la magie.
Donc, si nous sommes sur le point de dévoiler
le pouvoir des données
nous n'avons pas à suivre aveuglément
Orwell dans sa vision d'un futur totalitaire,
ni Huxley et sa vision d'un futur banal,
ni quelque horrible mixture des deux.
Ce que nous devons faire,
c'est respecter la pensée critique
et s'inspirer d'exemples
comme le Collectif Média Santé,
comme ils disent dans les films de superhéros
« Utilisons nos pouvoirs pour le bien ».
Merci.
(Applaudissements)